welcome to this video playing ice wide
shot from Denmark I think I played him
before yeah I did three games three
games three wins so let's see if I can
can keep this keep this serious on a
strictly I think you should call it a
streak arm Queen B 6 yeah this is this
is Pawn grab line where that does not
really have a good reputation no black
but I'm not not totally sure how you how
you are supposed to play it why does
some believe to get very good
compensation but I had this in a
tournament game once this white and it
didn't it didn't turn out to be that
brilliant how do you play now but should
be three Bishop c5 it's probably not not
that brilliant however but maybe Bishop
c5 week c1 something like that why
definitely has some has an active
position should i play Quincy 7 here
invading or how how do you how do you
play here not sure that it is really am
connected to a king side attack what I
should try him
hmm f6 f6 might be coming Quincy 394 is
a positional idea and maybe I can play
Bishop still a bishop be one at 23 not
easy
you know this whole line is not very
attractive in a way for black ass you
have so I mean it is it is somewhat
passive but I never felt that it is
super clear that why it has such a
fantastic compensation Queen B form
now wait okay it's a it's very
subjective here right here I might have
a b6 and 95 mm thats that's a problem
hmm poor that's not so great really
b6
hmm okay the I am that's not that's not
great that's not great
you might even put it on you for him
nice be three takes rook checks should
be seven yeah i'm just a pawn down yeah
this is a weird line if you somehow
somehow i don't really know how to how
to get to get the compensation that the
dwight should get I mean it cannot be
great this this variation really but
it's okay maybe this could this could
still be something in terms of
compensation I mean okay 19 at 17
brilliant maybe I can get some sort of
activity him takes Teague's yeah okay
come on put it on deform are really an
awful game I mean awful game is wrong I
mean I offer play by by me
I didn't get the slightest compensation
and knight c6 I'm also over looking
great yeah well I had this age 5 idea
but time morning and so I just just
executed it and didn't I didn't look at
much else maybe I can get some activity
with with Luke h1
f5 I don't have is six ok going for for
the for the fork check there may be here
check and it does not have a very good
position here for this for the pieces
but still this threatens made I can get
this check gtalk g8
maybe maybe 96 ideas my position was
much worse before but i only have 20
seconds now i'm running it in two nite
nite checks here night f2 is probably a
maid yes no I can take well the worst
thing is is that I'm not even
threatening anything rook age 3 as a
maid yeah i roped you too yeah this is
just lost wow what a crap game check yes
okay I resign white resides ah I totally
miss played this this bloody opening
what what did I do wrong here well it's
clear once you got to this this this
this thing with with with night on c5
it's really lopped not anything maybe
maybe I don't know
I mean my white definitely has
compensation that's clear but how do i
play this really then maybe this was a
bad idea it's not so clear to me how how
really I should play should I play more
on the C file to get to see 7 or do I
shift pieces to the Kings side I'm not
sure that this in general is so great
with but should be 3 and everything what
I did but I still I definitely have
enough compensation but how do I play
even Queen c7 comes into consideration
compounds to play Bishop e2 intending a
locum roots III that looks looks like a
good idea Renee but should be took
didn't didn't he came to mind what about
about this
Jim yeah it's not it's not overwhelming
or anything yeah I really don't know why
this line is so bad as this supposed to
be this way I really I really just a map
on down for very very little yeah I mean
I tried my best to confuse things I mean
he blundered here with with 96 but I
mean allowed that but I played age five
basically as a almost as a pre move so I
didn't really recognize what he did I
mean it looked like I I get against some
him some chances but probably check his
counter place always is good enough
rooks rooks you one now 44 draw it seems
now it's not I have 40 seconds so the
normal looking move is what I play but
here here he definitely has so he has
enough uh enough play here on his own
with Luke GA juke h5 my king is in big
trouble and I cannot really do anything
with the pawn in the night this is all
check oh well played yeah he already had
them made but this is here look b6 as a
draw funny enough yeah okay but I had 14
seconds I needed to play instantly check
this is check chances the maid checkmate
and here would be 6 seems to be a raw
honey why even wear a wait where exactly
is the draw
yeah this is something that only a
computer can can see so quickly I would
still think that us maybe I'm
threatening would be a trade trading
looks I can tell you what the comp line
is it wants to do this look at five and
then it says basically black should go
for for perpetual Oh tough yeah really a
deserved win for black I couldn't really
do anything in the opening okay thanks
for watching